well again we talked about it he could
get anywhere you want off the bounce and
we like that that's attacks I already
have seven assists but betas bond up to
get to the rim against Gibson
[Applause]
the game so much what more can you say
top billing
do that why not just go to that why you
doing it coming down and connecting on a
three ball oh he just bangs it on home
and that's a really smart timeout for
the Knicks because they could feel what
we were just talking about they've built
up this big lead why was two minutes to
go
let the Mavericks make this Lucca fueled
ruff take a look at Luke Oh like you're
saying things like that every single
night from this guy's City Smith gonna
get to take a look at Luke on the attack
and the finish
[Music]
[Applause]
take a look at the Luka three that right
in front of them show on a shooting hand
doesn't bother them up it 71 this kid's
got it all
stick around take a look at Luka into
the paint
yeah hide the back cookie drip only take
away the ego finds it man dead in the
court Luka with the offensive rebound
Dutchess finding the Sharpshooter
outside Tim Hardaway jr. oh and down it
goes
how about this nice feet here looking
one way throwing the other the MVNO
from the garden getting in better shape
pump fake let the man go by get the
contact and really shot on one leg er
this is a one leg er boy you know dirt
somewhere
look at this got the switch you want it
then afterwards that is some kind of
play by towel
whoo now tonight as
it's great three-point shooters second
Acton unlocks three-point shooters do it
alone to sport right here approach of it
get in the lane and size your touch
dodges being da judge he gets inside my
school find the Powell's in the house
vice the trap closed aunt about this guy
here you just said thirty on the world
to Levi the Mavericks San Antonio
scrambles forward and here comes a guy
doing it pretty snip to Luca docket and
hit the open trails great fine after
getting in the lane Georgian has been
outstanding
choose the basketball tonight
Bertie would be jealous
Lucca finds Dorian finney-smith that was
perfect oh my goodness
another dime not an easy path attacking
hit the paint again tonight wait until
the final seconds oh well I'll start to
finish
she's been sensational there's no
question about that and still tapped it
over to Seth Curry to put a lid on this
win and you know there's certain guys
certain coaches certain players in the
league
that they're like you have my goodness
I mean there is just they're given their
just overmatched right now they got to
find some spirit some energy really nice
passing no side out as you sees another
step back by daunted left
and look how smooth that stroke as we
said at some point he was going to get
the three points I have no idea like
what would you say I mean your teams
you're short-handed you really want me
to tell you what I would say and get
fire
Jen coming off to his right they're
trying to trap him right off the dribble
the LOB it's just great feel great
vision of course you would be brief
intriguing when you get opportunities
like this to school yeah Luka probit in
the lane of drawing defense lobbing it
up dribble handoff stop and pop Jalen is
probably coming in for him to stay on
dodging dodge it steps back Vijay gets
in his landing spaceman conscience
knocks it down on the glass hesitating
and then throwing up to this lob man
right there maxi Cleveland who obviously
got switched off rockets now there's no
help defender in there to protect the
rim you see Austin coming over his trip
and watch porzingis cutting in along the
baseline and he's tall enough look at
his hip slow down right laughs slow down
and then he gets clobbered in the face
by her Westbrook at over three minutes
in now it's Luca finding foul for it's
versus just for the game a moment ago I
say frequently that Luca gets inside
this size is strength
probe action
through the contact and the size to
finish on the inside and sometimes
Mookie's gonna find you when you're open
couple of updates and there you see the
n1 opportunities Lou come on attack
right around loony oh right around bang
since that time out of line while ago
plunge it shooted early things was
waiting for a ten point Phoenix lead the
Mavs have cut it in half on this Luca
layup Phoenix young players in the game
look at that move there that's very
difficult